[Música]
como foi falado e tanto foi provocado em
uma pergunta muito antiga
talvez remonte a shakespeare ou príncipe
charles não sei direito a pergunta é a
seguinte
pra que serve à humanidade e ele
respondeu não sei
é uma boa ideia mas nós precisamos
colocar em prática
então eu vejo que nós falamos aqui hoje
de escola de humanidade e de mudança é
nítido que nós queremos mudar
e nisto está implícito em cada um de nós
querer mudar quando nós notamos que
existe necessidade de mudar
nós nos damos conta que essa mudança
está implicada em uma incapacidade de
aceitar o que é se não houvesse
incapacidade de mudar o que é eu não
queria mudar
então nós queremos mudar a escola à
sociedade e veja há dois mil anos a
humanidade
vencendo que nós conhecemos
acidentalmente com humanidade e não
modificou muito alguém mostrou fotos
hoje da escola do século 19 e do século
20 e do século 21 com a mesma
organização
a mesma organização geométrica
então veja nós estamos tentando mudar
muitas coisas mas parece que nós não
mudamos ou não entendendo
o essencial que é o essencial
alguém também fez essa pergunta que tem
uma pergunta essencial à pergunta possa
aqui foi pra quê
ou porque nós existimos nós estamos aqui
não é curioso porque é uma pergunta
filosófica porque a pergunta que eu
trago para vocês que eu quero que você
examine não é porque nós estamos aqui é
quem está aqui veja alguém falou também
que o automóvel ayrton senna e dizia que
no momento de flow de estar totalmente
presente ele o automóvel era uma coisa
só
é brilhante significa que você não está
dividido
você perdeu a sua sensação de separação
das coisas
essa sensação de separação ela é uma
programação
ela é uma identidade nós estamos
identificados com algo nós aprendemos a
nos identificar com aula desde
pequenininho e ninguém questiona
necessariamente essa identificação todos
nós aceitamos essa identificação como
verdadeira como real mas a pergunta é
será que essa identidade que eu tenho é
réu
será que essa identificação que eu tenho
é verdadeira porque vejo se eu quiser
construir uma casa por onde eu começo a
construir a casa
obviamente eu começo pela fundação
então veja nesse momento qual é a
fundação do seu ser
quem é você o qq fundaç iona o que que é
essencial em você na verdade nós
não sabemos nós estamos o tempo todo
movendo os móveis de lugar dentro de uma
sala fechada e nós não procuramos nem a
porta nem sair pela porta nós ficamos
mudando os móveis de lugar
então o que eu quero dizer com isso nós
mudamos a escola de uma escola é
hierárquica autoritária é como é que se
como como ele disse aqui de repetição
que é provavelmente a que todos nós
passamos se inventou montessori o
outdoor suea outras variantes mas não se
mudou o que está por trás da escola que
está por trás da escola está por trás da
escola a nossa identificação a nossa
identidade
quem nós pensamos ser veja tem uma
pergunta clássica uma frase clássica
melhor dizendo
penso logo existo
todos sabemos de quem é eu suponho
tem uns logo existo
vou sublinhar de novo penso logo existo
pergunta se eu não penso eu não existo
porque está implicado eu penso que
existo porque penso 'se eu não penso eu
não existo
e aqui entra o paralelo que eu quero
fazer como a identificação
todos nós enchemos a boca para dizer que
somos humanos que são os seres humanos
ninguém discute mas veja eu
particularmente não tem nenhum orgulho
da humanidade
nenhum contudo que parece que nós
tenhamos feito eu não tenho orgulho a
gente ainda não resolveu a nossa relação
com o nosso semelhante amorosamente
está faltando algo
e esse algo que é ética ver pra que você
tem a carteira de identidade
todos vocês têm uma carteira de
identidade
pra quê pra provar que você é você
ninguém confia em você o sistema não
confie em você você está praticamente
determinado como um ser duvidoso
não é à toa que nós duvidamos de nós
mesmos
agora pergunta é quem é você
ninguém nos diz nem pode é você que tem
que descobrir a escola não diz poderia
não dizer mais questionar então quem é
você de verdade vejo ser humano é um
pensamento que nós aceitamos como verás
como verdadeiro mas nós somos mais
humanos que os animais porque pensamos
pensamos que somos melhor que os animais
porque pensamos somente isso não existe
prova concreta que sejamos nós
destruímos muito mais facilmente do que
os animais
então a questão aqui que eu ponho é que
ao invés de parar de continuar trocando
as coisas escolas e estruturas políticas
sociais e econômicas porque nós não
trocamos a nossa identificação básica
veja voltando ao carro do ayrton sena da
questão do flu
se eu estou presente o tempo desaparece
e as coisas que estão fazendo se tornam
absolutamente um deleite flor foi cena
ou o carro
são do senado não você está sentado na
cadeira completamente convicto de que
você está sentado na cadeira você está
completamente convicto de que você está
sentado na cadeira mas vejo meus amigos
e se você não estivesse sentado na
cadeira
se o que estivesse sentado na cadeira
fosse uma extensão de você sempre escuta
não você
mas o mais tensão de você então
praticamente objetivá mente na verdade é
o que nós deveríamos averigua e pra isso
nós precisaríamos criar umas relações os
parâmetros uns certos critérios
vejo vocês todos estão me vendo e mil
vindos e isso em forma vocês de uma
maneira objetiva prática que eu estou
fora de vocês não é mesmo
vocês me vêem e ouvem me podem sentir
que está a tocar
enfim acessar me através dos seus
sentidos
vejo isso é o critério que determina se
você é a extensão o corpo a extensão de
você ou você é o corpo
eu falei de identidade com que estamos
identificados com o que pensamos
tanto que a meditação vêem como um
alento para que nós paremos de pensar as
pessoas todas querem parar de pensar por
que será
porque não há silêncio silêncio não é
audível
nós não fomos o corpo não foi desenhado
para ouvir o silêncio o corpo houve
ausência
de ruídos ou ruído ruído organizado é
música
o silêncio é inaudível
o silêncio é onde o ruído ausência de
ruído ocorre então veja você está
sentado convicto de que é você que está
sentado mas eu te pergunto você se dá
conta que você está sentado ou você não
se dá conta que você está sentado
você se dá você se dar tanto conta de
que está sentado ou melhor ainda você
está consciente de que seu corpo está
sentado na cadeira tanto quanto você
está consciente de perceber o site
aprende falando pra você
então aqui entra um novo elemento nessa
equação que não é de segundo grau que eu
nem lembro que serve a equação é simples
você está sentado ou isso que está
sentada numa extensão de você
na nossa é história
pelo menos no ocidente ninguém ainda
levantou de verdade
a questão seguinte e se nós não apelar à
semus pra ética mas sim para a
consciência
a ética é uma estrutura mental que não é
confiável
não porque se goste ou não goste porque
eu gostar ou não gostar também uma
elaboração flutuante ela muda na hora eu
gosto não gosto
agora a consciência que você é o que
você tem
ela nunca muda
veja nesse momento você pode se ver
sentado na cadeira é absolutamente
impossível que você não se veja sentar
na cadeira
você não poderia dizer eu não estou
sentado na cadeira agora você até pode
dizer mas seria mentira
você nota é absolutamente provável que
você está sentado na cadeira o que
determina esse fato como é que você sabe
que você está sentado na cadeira
ora por que existe consciência
ea consciência que é semelhante ou
sinônimo ou equivalente ao silêncio
não dá pra ver com os olhos a
consciência não da província consciência
de verdade a consciência estense como um
corpo para reconhecer os outros objetos
no espaço para se relacionar com os
outros objetos no espaço então
humanidade é uma boa ideia mas eu acho
que nós não somos humanos
se nós voltarmos a nossa essência nós
descobríamos que nós não somos humanos
humano é um conceito que foi dado por
uma mente que pode ser melhorado
será que nós não somos extensão será que
o corpo não é uma extensão a mente não é
uma extensão para que eu tenha mão a
minha mão serve pra quê
mas na nossa identificação eu digo que
isso sou eu
mas isso não sou eu
isso é o que eu pareço ser pra você
se você percebe através dos sentidos
tudo que eu sou é o que aparenta ser
ou o que eu digo que sou que você pode
concordar ou não mas na verdade quem nós
somos está por trás disso
veja você seria exatamente uma outra
coisa ou melhor ainda uma não com isso
imperceptível pelos sentidos mas
totalmente consciente em si mesmo é que
existe uma operação direta a consciência
que você não precisa de o melhor não é
um objeto o qual o seu corpo ou somente
possa perceber
seria um absurdo matemático que você
pudesse encontrar a si mesmo
fora de si mesmo são os mestres antigos
dizem nós estamos e devemos olhar para
dentro o que olhar pra dentro é
fundamental
só que eu tenho uma questão que pra mim
surge lá no anos 80 que foi o seguinte
hoje é dentro porque eles dizem os
mestres que nós devemos olhar para
dentro e um dia dentro a mente tem uma
resposta o nosso interior dentro do
corpo quando você morre você sai do
corpo
existem indicações mas nada provável
agora veja só se eu abrisse o seu corpo
agora eu conseguiria tirar você aí
dentro
eu encontro você dentro do seu corpo
veja isso dentro do que os mestres falam
fosse fora do corpo e não fora do corpo
como aquela cadeira mas fora do corpo
então veja eu vou fazer uma experiência
com você aqui de sair do corpo
você tá vendo o seu corpo não você tá
está observando o seu corpo ou não
você sabe o que ele está sentindo você
sabe que somente está pensando se é
somente está concordando com o que eu
estou dizendo ou não
ou seja existe a mente pensante o corpo
sentindo
existe uma consciência vendo tudo
será que nós não somos essa consciência
veja aqui quase pra finalizar não seria
mais interessante deixar de ser humano e
voltar a ser a consciência do ser humano
nós estamos conscientes do ser humano
resolveria todos os problemas
aliás não tem problema nenhum
mas nós precisamos trocar de identidade
do corpo da mente do ego
na consciência porque a única coisa que
está com você todo tempo tento hoje de
noite você vai cantar perder a
consciência
veja se você consegue se você não
conseguir você a consciência
falei obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]